-Entertainment news --
we're just one month away
from the release of
Taylor Swift's
10th studio album,
"Midnights."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And fans are already finding
all kinds of secret messages
about the album in
her social media posts.
-Oh, man. All that stuff is just
conspiracy theories, though.
-Uh, I don't know, Tariq,
the clues are --
the clues are everywhere.
-What clues?
-Okay, so Taylor made a surprise
announcement at this year's VMAs
that her 10th studio album was
gonna be called "Midnights,"
and it would come out on
midnight on October 21st.
You follow?
-Uh --
-So, 13 is Taylor's favorite
number, and "Midnights"
is gonna have 13 tracks on it,
but nobody knows what the songs
are called yet.
On all the album art
she's shared so far,
all the songs have fake titles
like "Track One,"
"Track two,"
that kind of thing.
-And that means?
-But, when she posted a video
announcing
all the limited edition vinyls,
the names of the songs
were all blurred out on
the covers,
so you can tell the songs
won't actually be called
"Track One," "Track Two."
And that was on September 1st.
Then on September 16th,
she posted another video,
revealing that if you line up
the backs of all
the special edition vinyls
with the regular edition ones,
it makes a clock.
Midnight is a time on a clock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Okay, well, I guess --
-Yeah, but here --
here's where it gets
interesting.
[ Light laughter ]
In Taylor's entire discography,
she's only sung the word
"midnight" in six songs.
She sings it in "Style"
off of "1989,"
"You Are in Love" off of "1989,"
"New Year's Day"
off of "Reputation,"
"The Last Great American
Dynasty" off "Folklore,"
"Happiness" off of "Evermore,"
and of course,
in "22 (Taylor's version)"
of "Red (Taylor's version)."
[ Light laughter ]
And that's not even
the crazy part.
'Cause it also turns out
she's sung the phrase
"middle of the night,"
in seven songs
throughout her discography.
She sings it in "Ready For It?"
off "Reputation,"
"Daylight" off of "Lover,"
"You Belong With Me
(Taylor's version)"
off of
"Fearless (Taylor's version),"
"Untouchable
(Taylor's version),"
off of
"Fearless (Taylor's version),"
"All Too Well (10 minute
version) (Taylor's version)"
off of "Red (Taylor's version),"
"Better man (Taylor's version)"
and in "Nothing New
(feat. Phoebe Bridgers)
(Taylor's version)" off of
"Red (Taylor's version)."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are you even saying?
-Six "midnights" plus seven
"middle of the nights"
equal 13.
13 is Taylor's favorite number.
That's how many songs
are on "Midnights!"
Taylor's a genius!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I was getting at.
You get it now?
-Yeah, I get it.
Happy birthday.
-Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]